how CICS going for you it's going super
well this is the only public thing I'm
doing I've literally been in hotel rooms
having meetings trying to make some
[ __ ] money the whole time so just
meeting with clients mainly a couple of
emerging platforms but very focused on
you know what's interesting CES South by
can these big events I never go to the
stage
I don't consume the content I'm even
speaking less I just amusing a ton of
the opportunity to have the meetings
that I need to have over the next 120
days in one place so basically I come to
Vegas for three days to save five or six
days of travel in the net score so just
trying to be efficient yeah I think
everybody's curious what somebody like
you who is touching all points who makes
a mission out of connecting with people
and making sure that you know what's hot
what's new what people are thinking
about what kind of conversations you're
having here what are you seeing or who
are you meeting with that you're really
excited about what kind of technologies
are you seeing you're really excited
about
I think what's very unique about CES is
that people get very excited about
what's coming so I'm always a big fan of
and I know a lot of you feel some of you
here follow my content I'm very big on
day trading attention what that really
means is I like being practical I don't
I don't like when people think I'm a
futurist or or disruptor I don't think I
am
I actually think all I am is just very
practical I try to pay attention to what
you're paying attention to at scale
right now and how do I bring you value
in those environments so the thing
that's interesting to me here is
everyone's talking about you know voice
and IOT and Colet you know connected
this connected that which is absolutely
gonna happen I'm super excited about it
I can't wait to never leave my [ __ ]
room like it's all gonna be great but
for me I think it clouds a lot which is
there's a lot of company I would say the
far majority of companies here will go
out of business before the promise of
what they're trying to deliver on
becomes consumer at scale
and so for me I'm excited but tempered
in trying to help people stay alive for
the Holy Grail the you know there's a
lot of people in 2007 that thought
social media was gonna be big the
difference between me and a lot of them
was I knew how to stay alive from 2007
to 2013 before it became really real and
you know for me that's what CS always
reminds me which is great I can't wait
to have my robot you know wipe my ass
but before that happens make sure that
you're still in business in 2027 and so
there's a little bit too much 2027 talk
for me but at the flip side I love that
people are inspired excited meeting new
people
bouncing ideas thinking about things
differently and I would argue for
everybody I'm looking at right now if
you see something that allows you to
then use that as a proxy to be practical
over the next 24 months that to me is
interesting in the way I think about CES
yeah so where you were going there was
what I wanted to pick up because you
have an easy situation and that
everybody wants to come and talk to you
that is not the case for most people
here who are trying to grab attention
who are trying to find connections it's
a lot harder what is your advice to
folks who have to go out there and and
and and pursue instead of being pursued
yeah I mean look I think I think the
advice you know I'm a big fan of giving
advice I've actually taken myself you
know like I'm a big fan of eating my own
dog food
I used to come to events like this and
nobody knew who the hell I was and I was
in the wine business and it made no
sense for me to be here I'm an extrovert
it's comfortable for me to do what I
recommend these people which is if you
literally don't know each other it's
probably a good idea to say hello you've
got a common point of view of where the
world's going as many people as there
are here it's still a very tiny
percentage of the net score and so for
me it was comfortable to come to
something like this
listen to people and say hello grab a
business card send an e-mail try to
build a relationship I'm a big
believer in serendipity I didn't chase
the people on stage
I knew equally that the person sitting
right next to me in a 13 year macro
might be valuable to me and so my advice
to everybody who's not being chased down
and cameras and all this is to say hello
to the person next to them because
that's how life actually works now
there's a lot of people here that are
shy you know I grew up with parents that
had an accent this is an international
show like there's a million things that
I can run through my mind from the
psychology of why every person here now
won't look to the person to the left and
right and say hello it still doesn't
make the advice wrong that is the ROI
the ROI my friends everything you've
seen here you could watch on the [ __ ]
internet next week the ROI of coming to
this thing is to engage with the people
next to you right this second there's
nothing I'm gonna say right now that you
haven't heard me say in some other
version for the last [ __ ] decade and
you got to remember that everybody's
here to meet people that's a funny thing
is like you're yes you're right I mean
please no well you're you're you're
you're afraid of reaching out but you
want to connect and you have to remember
that the other people are thinking the
exact same thing when people come when
you ask people why did you come to
something like this why do you go to
some conference the answer is always to
meet other people that's always always
the number one thing it's not that like
watch some people on stage unless it's
you but otherwise it's - its - it's to
meet the people who are there yeah I
mean in South by Southwest 2007 Mark
Zuckerberg asked me to introduce him to
Kevin Rose the founder of Digg like like
you like the world changes and so you
know the people that get to sit on the
big stage things like this that the
other like they change but you have
access to everybody I mean there's
[ __ ] hundreds of thousands of people
here I'm just a very big fan of saying
hello versus pitching you know I wrote a
book called Jab Jab Jab right hook
because I really wanted to establish the
way I think of it which is I just think
that herb and Greg should know each
other I don't think that Greg should
pitch herb
his business I think they should just
say hello and create context and then
something may come from that and I just
believe in that I don't I don't know
what else to tell you I think it's very
practical let's let's talk some
technology Marco and guy is tag is
Robert now you know each other so you
already know each other right well
whatever so yummy fair media's got a
division called veer smart yes where you
are using new technologies or VR and
things to connect brands with consumers
talk to me about being on that cutting
edge how you stay on it I've got very
focused on IOT products free products
like literally your beer reordering
itself for you smart refrigerator being
more important than anything but the
reality is Vayner smart was named three
years ago when I started it and that the
promise didn't come true meaning it's
not moving as fast as I wanted to
thought it might so now what Vayner
smart does really is an obnoxious amount
of alexis skills and google home skills
and even podcast marketing which is very
basic that could be in media because
voice has become very real you know I'm
spending an enormous amount of time
thinking about that and so vein are
smart itself is probably gonna get
rebranded
because it's encompassing with AR and
machine learning
I'm starting to realize okay the things
that I know are gonna happen in a
10-year macro but I don't know exactly
when and how it's going to pop I need to
create a division where it's highly not
profitable because I'm just investing
and so vein are smart and some of the
m/l and AI and AR stuff is there and
then stuff that's even further out like
VR consumer or some of the connected
stuff we're seeing here that we'll just
sit in my investing world and networking
world not as an official Department
diagnose the problem was it because it's
hard to move an organization at the
speed that technology is changing
no the technology hasn't delivered on
the promise of its speed I don't know
one [ __ ] consumer product that's
reordered itself for itself for anybody
in this home like it's always about my
mistakes and my career are always timing
always like I understand consumer
behaviors so well that it's been my
calling card I really know that
everybody's gonna do a lot of things
here like online dating was obvious you
know I didn't think it was weird dudes
in their basements I thought it was
gonna be tender but and I invested in
your Bongo and won and highlight and
everything I got unlucky that tinder was
incubated inside of IAC
I knew that was gonna happen everybody
here is going to be very deep in IOT and
voice and order their toothpaste whether
that it's all happening it's not the
tech the technology so much of the
promise here is going to be four to six
years later than they said when they
talk to you at the booth so we move fast
as [ __ ] cuz I'm really losing money the
technology wasn't fast so how do you
stay are you looking are you trying to
plan out to the four to six years when
when when something that is talked about
now is actually going to only see
enacted yeah I mean I I lost a fortune
last year on voice strategists cuz I
could taste that it was gonna be now
right and and whether it was 2018
scopes which I've signed with clients or
2019 I knew it wasn't gonna be 2020 I
can't say that for a lot of the
technologies we see here so for me I'm
not scared if I think it's really close
within a year year and a half look I
bought cryptocurrency in 2014 but it
wasn't because I didn't know when or how
and I didn't even know if I really
didn't I just knew maybe or kinda or
probably or why it could and when you
play when you look at the world that
look I think
fundamental separation that I have is
really predicated on two things I have
empathy so I'm thinking about what
you're thinking about and number two I
don't care about money in the short term
if you really actually understand what I
just said on those two things if you're
actually consumer centric and you don't
need money in the short term you always
look like a [ __ ] genius do you have a
checklist in your head when you see a
new technology that you're like that
this is actually gonna this is actually
gonna come what is it when you when you
how do you analyze something and say
this is this is something I'm gonna see
now this is nothing I'm gonna see four
to six years this is something I'm gonna
see never is this something that Sally
and Rick that no dick [ __ ] about
technology are gonna be interested in
and then it's completely a subjective
call but and then that's number one but
the way I answer number one is will this
save somebody time I missed Ober early
but I got in early because I realized
very quickly after I didn't realize it
that they were selling time not
transportation the reason connected
devices and IOT is gonna work is it's
gonna save you time you don't want to go
to Duane Reade to buy band-aids
and sometimes I think people confuse
convenience with time you know
yeah like I I feel like I see things I
think I see some things here is using
elsewhere where it might be a better way
to do something but it's gonna take the
same amount of time to do it look that's
what's happening with e-commerce right
are you saving time by spending all of
January shipping ship back you know like
you got to look at these things it's a
super fascinating game I think that's
right you also have to think about
things that are nice to haves versus
necessities uber again just as a proxy
you've got to get to places that is a
must right a nice to have is a million
other things we could debate you know
but you
I mean look I think the barbershop will
be disrupted like for the most part not
for everybody but you got to get your
haircut right you know like you know I'm
coming don't worry you know and so I
think that uh I think that I think about
that like if people definitely do that
often scheduled all of that stuff will
be disrupted but most of all it's I
don't like people and I don't like
companies and businesses that are
ideological like there's way too many
enthusiasts here that would like to see
this [ __ ] happen I don't like to
anything to happen I just want to try to
figure out what I think is going to
happen and a lot of times that's put me
on in a place where people judged me and
made fun of me until they didn't all my
friends made fun of me that I signed a
case with sneaker deal because I had the
audacity to think it would work until it
all sold out in four hours and then they
stopped laughing and and the reason it
worked was because I understood where
attention sat right and and that's how I
think about the world when something
works you're a genius and when it
doesn't work you're a fool success has
unlimited fathers now everybody thinks
they were involved like Babin thinks
he's the reason the case with sneakers
sold right but failure has none right
yeah I mean look but that's what makes
it fun if you're in a place where you're
comfortable with accepting your losses
I'm proud to say up here that I've had a
pivot Vayner smart because the timing of
IOT hasn't worked in the way that I
thought it would that's comfortable to
me as you're watching the market yeah to
move that's comfortable I'm so sad that
so many of you don't do things because
you're worried about being judged it
makes me sad like that sucks
[ __ ] you know like to me that's my loss
like what's that got to do with you like
I don't give a [ __ ] what you think Marco
you know like like you know like I'm
doing my thing and so when you start
getting comfortable with losing in the
micro well then you can really start
doing things and so for me that's why
it's comfortable to day trade if you day
trade you're gonna miss a lot you just
have to make more than
miss and for me I just am comfortable in
that mentality when brands come to you
how comfortable are they with this ride
how comfortable are they with you
putting them in touch with something
that may not be ready or I don't sell
things that are not ready we didn't sell
any IOT only maybe strategy of like
educating them on where it potentially
could go so then that I asked the flip
do they want things because it's buzzy
even though you know it's not gonna work
sometimes but I don't let them unless
they prove to me that the headline in
TechCrunch or Ad Age has a viable
business reason other than them getting
promoted
not that they by the way not that they
listen to me like client services suck
[ __ ] like most of my client I mean
ninety a hundred percent of my clients
don't do what I think they should do 100
percent but but that's why I used my
personality as an outlet for me
creatively the garyvee thing is far more
a test bed for me create I'm far more
proud of being the architect of making
myself a personality or awareness than I
am that I'm it like that's more my
parents and my environment they get the
credit for me being a good guy and
having charisma that's not me I'm the
architect of how I got you to know who I
was in our story we put this guy on the
cover Jun the story about us about you
focus quite a lot actually on that on
that division between the personal brand
and the brand and it was interesting to
me I didn't realize the degree to which
you wanted those two feel separate yeah
I mean look I I don't want to be a
charlatan or a motivational speaker or
you know those aren't interesting to me
but I'm also willing to people to judge
me and misunderstand me because I know
how this all plays out at the end so you
can do me in the second quarter I'll
talk to you after the game
and I like the way that you think of
yourself as an R&D lab that's what
you're you're testing you're testing
things on
self that you think are going to play a
payout yeah I mean like I didn't invest
in Facebook and Twitter and uber and
snapchat and buy cryptocurrency in 2014
and launched the e-commerce site in 1996
by accident like I didn't create a brand
that allowed me to sign a sneaker deal
bigger than 99 percent of athletes by
accident none of this is [ __ ]
accident this is me being willing to eat
[ __ ] and have humility and take negative
feedback while I try to figure [ __ ] out
I work I do [ __ ] like while everybody's
debating I'm doing it and I'm willing to
take micro losses for macro wins and
most people aren't because they want
short term money or they actually value
other people's opinions over their own
on the subject of negativity towards
technology I guess I mean this is this
is slightly selfish that I got a pivot
into this but I think it's apropos for
the for the setting so I haven't spot
guys called pessimist archive history of
unfounded fears of Technology where we
look at things that why people feared
and banned stuff that today we think of
is totally normal
Gary I know you're familiar with it and
I love that you are also passionate
about calling out when people say that's
something that new some new technology
is gonna change us in some terrible
fundamental way I mean the number of
things that are gonna come out of this
show that then people are gonna talk
about for six months it's gonna ruin the
way that we converse it's gonna ruin the
way that we are as humans and I wonder
from your perspective how you address
that conversation when people say this
technology is it's fundamentally bad I
don't agree with them I think you know
go google the Kaleidoscope kids have
something in front of them and I was
gonna ruin they're like you know this
you have the account I mean we tripped
into that when we were hanging out we
are lying on this my level of respect
for Sean Parker and Chamath
professionally because I don't know them
super well is extraordinary
it's extraordinary I grew up during that
era they're brilliant
I completely disagree with their current
headline-grabbing statements about
Facebook technology is exposing who
actually our it's not changing who we
are we're struggling to deal with the
fact that we have a lot of shortcomings
that we've been able to hide before in
our personality traits not Facebook
changed me guys like people like Oh
everybody shows their best life on
Instagram and everything's perfect
that's what we always did we just had a
coffee with our friend and said
everything was [ __ ] great
like like technology is exposing who we
actually are and demonizing technology
of the moment is always always
historically incorrect I totally agree I
feel like the way I think of it is that
the the shape of things change but the
thing doesn't change I have no interest
in listening to billionaires that made
billions on products than [ __ ] on those
products cuz they're altruistic I just
don't I just don't agree by the way I
may end up being wrong it's all on
[ __ ] film I just have a funny feeling
I won't yeah well we survived many
before are you kidding me like [ __ ]
everything was supposed to kill Mike
Tyson's punch-out was supposed to ruin
my [ __ ] life the bicycle the car the
Walkman it's the same [ __ ] it's band at
the Walkman like oh now you're stuck in
your stream on social but it was way
better for you to watch television for
nine hours a day and have three old
white guys tell you what to think like
we're being so naive this is about my
friends life is about choices either we
have the collective voices and you I I
laugh about Facebook Facebook doesn't
make me watch Russian hackers content me
engaging with the things that are put on
Facebook show me Russian hacker content
you want to see how Facebook bigs
everything you know what nobody uses
Facebook search you want to see how
Facebook actually works before we
demonize Facebook go to Facebook search
right now type in hockey don't like 17
pieces of content that show up and watch
[ __ ] hockey content gets shoved down
your [ __ ] throat
over the next two months these looks not
penetrating you and changing your mind
there's no [ __ ] Russian hacker that
got you you [ __ ] actually thought
those things you just don't like it
amen it's truth and we just don't want
to deal we want to blame everybody but
our [ __ ] selves we have zero [ __ ]
accountability you have subconscious
bias deal with it period sorry but it's
the [ __ ] truth it's not [ __ ]
Facebook's fault that you're a [ __ ]
racist
you can take those photos of people who
are all sitting in a group looking at a
phone truth it's just like like why are
we not having the real by the way by the
way on a serious macro I'm pumped I
actually think this is our societal step
backwards for two steps forward like
this is painful we're all dealing with
it it doesn't feel great it's negativity
at scale like I suffocate in negativity
so the macros like [ __ ] this sucks but
this is one big step backwards a ten
years by the way this doesn't stop over
a day but we're gonna take massive steps
forward because of this because the
truth is always the best conversation
and let me remind you who is hiding the
truth the traditional media company's
not Facebook so [ __ ] you guys like I'm
so pissed at that that is such lack of
accountability and then people posturing
after they made their money [ __ ] yeah
wait I want you to expand more on that
traditional media company is hiding the
truth Matt Lauer got away with it
because of NBC and ABC in the Wall
Street Journal not because of Facebook
and Twitter the Internet is now the
media company period which means
everybody has an at-bat there's there's
the commerce and branding side of it
which I love like why would I still be
in New Jersey with a bunch of liquor
stores if the internet didn't come along
like you know like like there's a lot of
that but like there's a lot of like when
there's when you could literally call
Rupert Murdoch can be like your bro
you've got some reporter at Fox that's
investigating me like shut that [ __ ]
down and they did that's how the world
worked that's not how it works anymore
that's the bottom line so that's what I
mean like you decide what the [ __ ] in
Entrepreneur Magazine I do like doesn't
mean I decide who is an entrepreneur
that's for sure but but guess what you
kind of do because like what I mean by
that is and we will do that it's just
that we all can do that now like every
single person here can use that this
distribution has been commoditized I as
a personality as a human have as much of
an entrepreneur mac-like audience as now
media come I mean that's absurd that is
unbelievably transformative it's not
just that but then media companies come
to you because they want to reach your
audience 100% and it works back and
forth it's leverage of attention I'm
just so happy that the truth has
momentum and we're look it's gonna
change us tremendously because not one
of us including me doesn't have human
shortcomings and we're gonna need to
reconcile that the era of hypocrisy is
in trouble like we're gonna we're gonna
eat [ __ ] have a lot of casualties but
then we're gonna our grandkids are gonna
live in a world where we accept each
other's shortcomings way more than we do
now because nobody's gonna be able to
hide ten years ago a lot more people
went to the strip clubs last night now
with media everywhere a lot of people
rethought their decisions last night the
world's change that just real that's
just the truth like so I think that's
fascinating I think that plays out in a
million different ways I don't know that
you'll even have an answer to it but
just to play the other side yeah
anything concern you what do you see
that concerns you
nothing I'm being serious let me tell
you why I like data here's my punchline
we human beings have done a really good
[ __ ] job adjusting along the way you
know it's way scarier than Russian
hackers
the Black Plague I don't know like like
[ __ ] concentration camps seem a hell
of a lot scarier to me contextually then
make it selfies so here's what's scary
we forget how terrible that [ __ ] was
right that's how it gets repeated that's
right we forget that we had those fears
we forget that we fought the battles
there's people literally mad that people
gave them skim milk instead of almond
milk in this audience right now but do
you understand how [ __ ] up [ __ ] is
like we have zero perspective people a
good friend of mine who knows me super
well last night at a dinner or two
nights ago said to me like was acting
weird with me and like we got into a
little conversation and I it was kind of
razzing me subconsciously that I only
put out positive content and that that
it's a facade and this is like like if
any of you said that I'd be like I
totally get it let me explain but if
somebody have fairly knows me for like a
decade I was at his wedding right I
don't go to a lot of weddings for
context so like tight um and it was
fascinating to me I was like wow people
are uncomfortable with people that have
really like my mom is the same way like
I just have unbelievably deep
perspective which is the following
unless the eight people that I love the
most are really sick everything else
means dick I mean that Maria like that
like I don't I mean I'm gonna struggle
to lose money today or somebody said I
was a you know when at age said - what
the [ __ ] moment was my sneaker and
razzed me like or like like that means
nothing so what what scares me as a
collective nothing in the micro the
health and well-being of the people I
love the most
everything else is controllable
everything else is my fault you you know
something we have in common is that
we're both in positions to build off of
what you just said we're both in
positions
of positivity it's actually I feel very
fortunate about it because like inside
me I don't know about inside you but
inside me I've got I've got a lot of
enthusiasm and positivity I've also got
a lot of deep skepticism but I know that
what people want for me is positivity
that's valuable to them and so it puts
me in that place where I can feel that
the most where I can exude that the most
and I think you're probably funny I have
come to finally realize that I realize
that I mean nothing which then doesn't
allow me to have the audacity to be
cynical or or skeptical it's you know
when I think my late parents having sex
at the right moment giving me DNA like
this is not me but I'm like why am I not
skeptical why am I not cynical oh
because the [ __ ] does my opinion mean in
that for like like the amount of people
dropping their two cents on social media
to [ __ ] on somebody like they mean
something people try to build the
biggest building in town by tearing
everybody else's building down when you
have enough talent to just build the
biggest building you just build the
biggest building I could give a [ __ ]
about anybody else I'm doing me and
honestly I wish all of you the best and
I even really hope you beat me because
that will keep me hungry but the truth
is I'm not worried about other people
[ __ ] like we're just we're counting
everybody else's points too much worry
about your own [ __ ] so we got a few
minutes left and let's do it by building
people up if we're just talking about
that great so we had conversation with
Samsung folks here just before you came
on where they were asking me Samsung's
looking a partner with barrier to
redefining people really amazing
entrepreneurs who are pushing boundaries
I said you know they should ask it
should ask you and actually [ __ ] that
why don't I just ask you on stage put
you on the spot who should we all be
really excited about so one of the
things that I spew it's funny you asked
me that question
off of what I just said I'm spending
almost zero time paying attention to
anybody else so I struggle with this
and then the only answers i know are
people that are really within my circle
so i hate this question because my head
goes to a funny couple places right
rachel Tippa graph but i invested in her
company so feels self-serving so I hate
thing I've never give the answer but the
only reason I know is cuz I said on the
board and I watch her navigate and I
think she's a ninja and an incredible
entrepreneur right I think she's special
so like the answer is the names I know
are like 20 people all who are
self-serving so outside of Rachel won't
name any of them but it's the ones that
I can actually see what they're actually
doing and there's a lot of people doing
incredible stuff and a ton of people I'm
just not you know as you can tell I'm
very passionate about the [ __ ] I know I
get really quiet when I don't know and
the truth is I really don't know I
really don't know I'm not paying
attention to that I spend 100 percent of
my time on consumer behavior I care
about what you're gonna do
I obsess over it I spend 18 hours a day
over it I figure out why eight-year-old
girls make slime I try to figure out why
champion went from being a private-label
at Walmart to the brand that has the
most swag in the streets I try to think
about what cardi B did I try to think
about you know what's going on on
YouTube kids and like why is Siri every
six-year-olds best friend like I am like
that's what I spend my time on you're
amazing at knowing their answer that's
what you guys spend your time on so I I
suck [ __ ] at 98% of things it's in that
2% that I'm gonna be all time but your
answer actually brings us full circle to
the beginning of our conversation which
is about meeting people and discovering
how great they are because your answer
is well are the people that I know I've
gotten to understand what their
strengths are what their genius is and
so the answer is going on just sends it
to everybody you go expand your network
and then you understand the great
resources in people that you have around
you I think so and I think you know I
think it's interesting there's a lot of
variables to why somebody gets put on a
pedestal and I'm listen I am massively
benefiting from having a lot of sizzle
but the only way to win long-term is to
have this
take and and I I'm always trying to be
thoughtful of like what's and I think
sizzle special like I don't down like oh
you like to have sizzle means something
that's by the way most of the people you
know but I'm going to say who's a great
entrepreneur it's somebody that I think
is gonna be sitting there yeah look guys
we live now through literally almost
nine years of complete global economic
growth [ __ ] has been great like when I
look at everybody under 30 in here and
I'm like oh my god never in their
professional life have they hit a
tremendous recession or a massive market
crash like there's not a lot it's it's
so fun like I'm looking around like I
would say I don't know 65 70 percent of
everybody's faces I see here didn't even
live through 2008 let alone 2001 let
alone the mid 90s like like it's super
easy right now there's so much money in
the system all these entrepreneurs
startup people that everybody looks up
to they lose money every month it
doesn't take a hero to lose money every
month everybody here can lose money
every month
I've run businesses for 22 years of my
life every day of my life and I've never
ever ever raised any capital and I've
made money every single year like that's
a skill set so that's what a great
entrepreneur is to me not riding a
golden era and was able to raise capital
she or he know running a business now
that bubble will burst and then we'll
get to see who's still around and then
we'll see everybody else who says
entrepreneur in their Instagram profile
right now when they're working in Bank
of America and 24 months and so that's
what I'm waiting for I'm I'm most
excited for and waiting for and hoping
for complete global economic carnage so
that we can weed out the B and C and D
players well Jesus if you would stop
talking a minute ago we would have ended
on a high note but instead we ended on
that I don't think by the way that's
where I think this is so fun I think
that is a high note it's the same way
I'm looking at what's happening now the
truth should
Wyn if you're a piece of [ __ ] you should
lose if you're not a good entrepreneur
you should have a job merit and the
truth are always the winners in the
macro we're just in a micro right now
and people are confused everyone you
have your mission introduce yourselves
to each other and give it up for Gary
thanks guys
[Music]